so in the last episode I talked about
eight creative ways to find time to read
for those that say I don't have any time
to read today I want to share with you
the ten commandments of reading
commandment number one
thou shalt not read crappy books the
next time you're at a bookstore and
you're thinking about picking up a
possibly a romance novel with some
shades of gray
once you pick up a book with some shades
of personal development in it
commandment number two thou shalt not
listen to music with lyrics while
reading there's nothing wrong with
listening to Hans Zimmer or Mozart or
white noise while reading the book but
your brain will get confused if you're
trying to read a book and listening to
jay-z or Justin Bieber at the same time
commandment number three thou shalt read
multiple books at the same time to
prevent your brain from getting bored
with the book I suggest reading three
different types of book a biography a
novel and a business book commandment
number four thou shalt never lend a book
instead give books away I think a reader
becomes emotionally attached when you
read a book and you have left marks and
their highlights and they're said
there's no reason to lend a book to
somebody else instead go buy 10 copies
of that book and give it away
commandment number five thou shalt not
merely skim through books there are many
people that are call themselves expert
and they'll say there are 10,000 books
but all they do is ring the bullet
points and the headlines and that's it
you see to me the purpose of reading is
to learn and to teach and the best most
effective way to teach others is through
stories so if you just read the
headlines you'll miss the stories
commandment number six thou shalt
silence your inner voice while reading
there's nothing worse than trying to
read a book while you have all this
stuff on your mind what am i wife say
that earlier why did I get into that
fight with my mom I can't stop what my
boss told me today
try to eliminate all those thoughts in
your mind and focus on reading the book
commandment number seven thou shalt take
notes and highlight
I love seeing readers that carry around
books a lot of wear and tear because it
tells me that that person not just
reading the book they're they're
studying the book they're taking notes
they're highlighting things they're
marking things in there and what this
allows you to do is to revisit the book
three six twelve months later and reread
the content you read and retain that
information commandment number eight
thou shalt join a book club one of the
great things about being part of a book
club is the fact that allows you to see
what others read in the book that maybe
you didn't catch and also helps you
become accountable to a group of people
that you read in a book with commandment
number nine
thou shalt share what one has learned
the best way to retain the information
you get from any book is to share it
with somebody else immediately
commandment number 10 thou shalt
encourage others to read imagine having
access to the most powerful computer in
the world they never turn on really
think about that because I believe our
mind or brain is by far the most
powerful computer in the world and many
people don't use it this is why I
believe there's nothing like encouraging
others to read because when we do and
they start realizing the possibilities
or what they're capable of doing that's
when their eyes open up to a whole new
life
I'm Patrick with your host evalute Amit
thanks so much for watching this episode
bio if you missed the last episode we
did eight creative ways on how to find
time to read click on the link right
here to watch that episode and be sure
to subscribe to this channel as well on
the bottom and stay tuned for the next
episode